the Sun is finally shining in Verona
lousiest Simon was waiting for this
moment he's heading for the amphitheater
a famous venue where some of the world's
best opera singers perform and for just
a few days it's the stage for Siemens
art he calls his car mirror installation
signature of light he needed five days
to set up he first proposed the project
in 2011 then Simon spent a year and a
half going through a bureaucratic jungle
now he can hardly believe that his
project is actually happening I know if
it's yellow it was really an official
act dance listen I was given the arenas
key and it's practically been my
apartment for five days now that's
fantastic it wasn't much time siemens
assistant the condo malio nancy enlisted
the help of around 30 friends to do the
setup the veronese native also had to
interpret and make sure the group gelled
first time that we met was very funny
because I was a leg broken and it was in
the morning at eleven o'clock and he was
like like eyes like this I said well
this is the guy who should help me it's
like okay okay let's go for it just a
few hours later the installation of
2,500 old car mirrors was already taking
shape but heute is for absolute or
moogly she doesn't I thought it was
gonna be impossible I never thought it
would work but at the same time I also
thought that I'll never be allowed to do
this at a monument with UNESCO Heritage
status so even though I thought it was
impossible i was really tempted to try
desmia my slides estufa zucconi lousiest
seaman visited the Opera Festival in
Verona in 2011 from that point on he
just couldn't stop thinking about the
arena he wanted to make his mark on the
2000 year old structure up until now he
set up installations in natural
surroundings the first was in the
Namibian desert in 2009 light has always
fascinated him and he's designed his own
symbol for it
he links i got the vertical axis
longitude and then there's the
horizontal axis latitude and then
there's the Earth's movement around the
two brightest points DJ fundido seen
come in 2011 he lit up lan Sirota in the
Canary Islands he went to Ireland the
same year
his glittering art installation could
even be seen from space back in Verona
lousiest Simon and his team used the
same car mirrors that were used in the
other installations
he sets them up on movable mounts the
wind then determines in which direction
they reflect later they're brought into
their precise position lousiest semen
found the mirrors in German and Namibian
junkyards for him there for more than
simple car parts
it's because they've been looked into a
thousand times in the rearview mirrors
have reflected thousands of stories they
didn't record them of course but things
happened so they have a certain historic
fontina the light goes in and those
stories are sent into space station that
we dance alexander's the sky clears for
a moment now everyone is hoping for sun
otherwise there won't be much reflection
going on eight hours later the helpers
have finished work for the day many
thanks John for Kandra I would like to
ask him to install the last mirror
you
ciuman then views his entire work for
the first time from the top of the
amphitheater back when you can realize
that we actually did it we got two and a
half thousand mirrors into this arena
unbelievable but it's really best seen
from the air the artist says the symbol
is a tribute to the venerable
amphitheater now it's time to move on
there are many more places for lousiest
CM on to leave his mark next on his
agenda are a lavender field in Provence
and the plaster trocadero in Paris